mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les maires les élus mesdames et
messieurs les directeurs
d'administration
mesdames et messieurs les garants du
grand débat national
mesdames et messieurs trois mois environ
après son lancement par le président de
la république le grand débat national
s'achève aujourd'hui
ces trois mois ils ont été intenses ils
ont pu paraître trop court à certains
ils ont peut être paru trop long à
d'autres je crois qu'ils étaient
nécessaires nécessaire pour donner la
parole aux français
on regrette parfois l'accélération et la
brutalité du débat public
l'accélération et la brutalité du temps
politique
on ne doit pas je crois si on la
regrette s'impatienter dès qu'on donne
la parole aux français ce temps que nous
avons consacré un grand débat national
il était nécessaire pour laisser à
chacun la possibilité de s'exprimer et
il était nécessaire pour écouter si on
ne prend pas le temps d'écouter en
général on n'entend pas bien il était
nécessaire
pour laisser les thématiques que nous
avions retenu s'installer dans le débat
public
ça prend pas comme ça et c'était aussi
nécessaire d'avoir du temps pour laisser
le temps à d'autres thématiques qui
n'avait pas été posée dans le débat
public d'émerger et de prendre leur
importance les premiers mots au fond
sont des mots de remerciements de
remerciements aux français à tous ceux
qui ont pris le temps d'écrire une
contribution de répondre à un
questionnaire en ligne de remplir un des
seize mille cahiers citoyens disponibles
dans les mairies en vérité plus de 16
mille cahiers puisque c'est dans seize
mille mairie qu'il ya eu des cas tous
ceux qui ont pris le temps de participer
à des réunions publiques
tu vois même assisté à quelques unes de
ces réunions
allez nax dans l'allier madame la
députée à sartrouville dans les yvelines
dans d'autres endroits de france avec
des réunions où il y avait parfois
beaucoup de monde et d'autres beaucoup
moins
toutes ces réunions ont été
passionnantes
elles ont permis et tous les français
qui se sont exprimés
on dit et on souhaitait réfléchir et
s'exprimer sur l'avenir de leur pays ils
se sont interrogés sur ce qui fonctionne
parce qu'il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent
c'est d'ailleurs réjouissant de
constater que à l'occasion des débats
nos concitoyens pointe du doigt des
choses qui fonctionnent le savent
parfaitement
et puis aussi de permettre d'identifier
et de réfléchir sur ce qui ne fonctionne
pas ou sur ce qui fonctionne mal
c'est un temps où nos concitoyens ont
échangé entre eux où ils se sont écoutés
contrairement à ce que certains
redoutaient ces réunions publiques se
sont déroulées dans des conditions
d'ordre public exemplaire
vous l'avez dit madame tout à l'heure à
juste titre ces réunions ont fait
honneur à leurs participants elles ont
fait honneur à notre pays dont chacun
sait le goût pour la politique l'envi de
nos concitoyens de refaire le monde de
refaire la france elles ont fait honneur
d'une certaine façon au débat
démocratique
en étant très loin des exemples de
violences que d'autres se complaisent à
donner chaque samedi à l'occasion de ces
réunions
je crois pouvoir dire que nous avons
reconquis des espaces publics dans
lesquels il est possible d'échanger avec
respect plutôt que de s'insulter dans
l'anonymat et si j'insiste c'est parce
qu'il y à trois mois lorsque nous avons
langer lorsque nous avons lancé
je suis coutumier du fait
j'ai un passif très fort en la matière
lorsque nous avons lancé le grand débat
et bien beaucoup pas forcément
d'ailleurs ceux qui étaient hostiles par
principe aux grands débats mais beaucoup
étaient très très inquiet sur la
capacité que nous aurions à tenir des
réunions dans des conditions d'ordre et
de respect et d'écouté satisfaisant cela
était possible
je voudrais remercier les gars en dur en
débat les remercier d'avoir accepté une
mission que d'autres ont refusé accepter
une telle responsabilité
c'est forcément s'exposer dans ce débat
rien ne devait être cachés certes et
vous l'avez dit nous avons un peu cadrer
les choses pour lancer la discussion
mais très vite évidemment c'est la
liberté de parole qui a pris le relais
toutes les données sont désormais
disponibles elles sont ouvertes à tous
ceux qui voudront les analyser il n'y a
pas une lecture officielle du grand
débat il y à des données qui sont
disponibles pour que chacun puisse les
saisir les interroger sans inspirer le
cas échéant contesté la façon dont nous
les lirons ou dont elles ont été lues ce
matin et ces données seront disponibles
disponible aussi longtemps que
nécessaire cet engagement de
transparence nous le devions aux
français et je voudrais remercier je le
dis les garants de leur regard
scrupuleux exigeant qui nous a parfois
conduit à nous remettre en question dans
les choix d'organisation qui pourrait
être proposé leurs conseils leurs
critiques nous ont aidé à bâtir une
méthode innovante sans doute perfectible
mais honnête
ce qui est l essentiel je voudrais aussi
remercier les représentants et les
membres des trois assemblées qui ont
joué le jeu de cet exercice de
démocratie participative je salue
notamment la présence du président
bernasconi
je voudrais remercier les formations
politiques celle de la majorité comme
celles de l'opposition qui ont organisé
facilité
fais en sorte que la tenue des réunions
publics soit possible je voudrais aussi
remercier les élus locaux
à commencer par les maires de france
sans qui ce débat n'aurait eu de grands
que le nom très vite ils ont couvert
d'écaillés dans leur mairie
partout ils ont accepté de céder des
salles
beaucoup ont participé à des réunions
[Musique]
merci monsieur je disais donc merci à
tous ceux qui ont choisi de faire en
sorte que les réunions se passent dans
l'ordre et dans les côtes
[Applaudissements]
et donc merci au maire qui ont rendu
possibles ces réunions qui les ont
organisées dans bien des cas beaucoup
ont participé à des réunions
beaucoup l'ont fait avec une forme de
distance tout à fait légitime et que je
comprends parfaitement
parce que ils ont considéré que
l'important était l'expression pas
forcément qu'il leur revenait à eux de
répondre à des questionnements enfin je
voudrais remercier les organisations
syndicales les associations qui ont
relayé cet appel au débat et qui ont
parti fait participer aux conférences
nationales thématiques sans oublier les
médias qui d'une certaine façon ont eux
aussi su innover pour se mettre au
diapason de ce grand moment de
démocratie participative et rendre
visibles de nombreux échanges citoyens
parfois rude
j'en ai connu mais je leur dis toujours
respectueux merci enfin si vous me le
permettez à la mission du grand débat
qui n'est pas l'organisme le plus
visible dans la réalisation et
l'organisation de ce grand débat mais
qui est fait de femmes et d'hommes qui
ont été la cheville ouvrière et qui ont
rendu possible cette expérience inédite
et merci aussi aux deux ministres qui
ont animé et organiser les choses
pardon si ses remerciements vous semble
un peu long mais après tout ils en
disent long aussi ce succès celui du
grand débat ça n'est pas le succès du
gouvernement c'est celui du france des
français de tous les français
le président de la république en a lancé
l'idée nous en avons conçu les outils
mais une proposition et des outils à eux
seuls
ça ne fait pas un débat un débat ça ne
marche que si les femmes et des hommes
sont en part si le nourrissent s'il le
modifie si le densifie s'il agite et
cela il n'ya que l'intelligence
collective qui en est capable et en
l'occurrence celle du peuple français
alors c'est évidemment difficile de
résumer en quelques mots ou par un
discours les dizaines de millions de
mots et les centaines de milliers
d'idées qui ont été exprimées par nos
concitoyens
nous avons essayé de le faire ce matin
en toute honnêteté mais quel que soit
son format tout synthèse paraîtra
toujours un peu réductrice
nous n'avons pas ce matin évoqué des
choses que j'ai moi même entendu dans
des débats je pense par exemple à ces
remarques assez récurrente formulées par
des femmes et singulièrement par des
femmes qui élevait des enfants et qui
disait combien le régime des pensions
alimentaires le non-respect des pensions
alimentaires l'aimé t elle
indépendamment de l'état dans une
situation d'une immense fragilité
nous n'avons pas évoqué ce matin les
situations individuelles mais souvent
évoqué deux femmes là aussi travaillant
dans le secteur de la dépendance dans
les ehpad multipliant les contrats
courent dans des conditions évidemment
délicate et difficile
il n'est pas anormal que nous n'ayons
pas pu évoquer toutes les situations
individuelles qui était au coeur de ce
grand débat mais nous avons tous
conscience ici que cette synthèse est
forcément justement ça une synthèse et
qu'elle n'a pas l'exhaustivité comme
objectif nous avons voulu un débat libre
un débat foisonnant je tiens à ce terme
pour que toutes les nuances pour que
tous les possibles s'exprime et de fait
le débat était libre et foisonnant on
voit bien par exemple que la thématique
de la santé s'est invitée dans les
questions que nous avions posée aux
français
l'accès à un médecin traitant
l'organisation l'accès aux tissus
hospitalier tous ces sujets sont au
coeur des proches des préoccupations des
français est en vérité partout sur le
territoire
partout sur le territoire et je n'en
suis pas surpris car dans ma vie de mère
depuis 2017
j'entends nous entendons tous cette
préoccupation monter cette difficulté
d'accéder à un médecin
cette angoisse sourde et d'ailleurs pas
toujours sourde lorsque le médecin
traitant que l'on connaît depuis
toujours par à la retraite et qu'il n'y
a personne
pour le remplacer cette angoisse existe
elle a été formulée pendant le grand
débat n'était pas suscité il faut
évidemment l'entendre et je tenais à
l'indiquer ici et aujourd'hui après
avoir écouté avec attention la
restitution qui a été faite ce matin
avoir écouté avec une égale attention
les français que j'ai rencontrés dans le
cadre des réunions publiques auxquelles
j'ai participé je retiens pour ma part
un immense besoin de justice et d'équité
et quatre grands axes quatre exigences
certaines d'entre elles étaient déjà
fortement ressentie et en cela le débat
a permis de confirmer un certain nombre
d'orientations d'autres plus nouvelle
implique de changer d'appproche de
changer de méthode et peut-être même de
changer d'échelle
la première exigence c'est en fait une
immense exaspération fiscale cette
exaspération ne date pas d'hier
mon gouvernement assume sa part de
responsabilité
il en a d'ailleurs tiré un certain
nombre de conséquences en annulant la
hausse de la taxe carbone mais bien
avant la hausse de cette taxe
cette exaspération avait atteint des
sommets dans toutes les catégories de la
population dans les foyers comme dans
les entreprises les grandes mais surtout
les petites
dès notre arrivée nous avons baissé les
cotisations sociales baisser la taxe
d'habitation baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés sans doute pas assez vite sans
doute pas assez fortement sans doute pas
assez clairement car manifestement cela
n'a pas suffi à répondre ras-le-bol
notre pays a atteint aujourd'hui une
sorte de tolérance fiscale 0 c'est pas
si on peut l'appeler comme ça mais c'est
souvent comme ça qu'elle est exprimée
les débats je le crois nous indique
clairement la direction à prendre
nous devons baisser et baisser plus vite
les impôts les français ont aussi
compris avec beaucoup de maturité
beaucoup plus en tout cas que certains
acteurs institutionnels du débat
politique qu'on ne peut pas baisser les
impôts si on ne baisse pas à la dépense
publique les français ne veulent pas du
yaka fokon ils ne nous disent pas
seulement qu'il faut baisser les impôts
ils ne nous disent certainement pas
qu'il faut creuser la dette et nous
encourage à prendre des responsabilités
à prendre des décisions
être responsable des décisions que nous
prenons la deuxième exigence
elle va avec sept priorités évoquées à
la justice c'est une exigence de
fraternité de proximité de lien
quotidien
parmi les millions de mots que
j'évoquais certaines reviennent avec une
terrible régularité celle isolement
c'est l'abandon
c'est l'indifférence c'est le manque
d'attention le manque de considération
nous vivons dans un pays où à certains
endroits on ne se voit plus où on ne se
parle plus et quant à son tour le
service public fermes ou des ménages
c'est l'état qui bien souvent le dernier
rempart qui abandonne aussi la réponse
à ce profond malaise consiste
probablement à rétablir l'équilibré
entre les métropoles et les communes qui
se trouvent à l'extérieur des logiques
métropolitaine la bonne nouvelle c'est
que je crois que c'est possible
il y a 20 ans 30 ans l'enjeu c'était de
rééquilibrer les activités et le
dynamisme entre paris et ce qu'on
appelait la province on y est assez
largement parvenu notre pays dispose
aujourd'hui de puissantes métropole qui
rayonne en europe qui réussissent dans
la mondialisation
on doit maintenant faire le même travail
de rééquilibrage entre ces métropoles et
les communes petites ou moyennes qui ont
encaissé le choc le contrechoc d'une
certaine façon de ce développement
rapide et qui n'en profitent pas assez
on devra aussi peut-être revoir nos
règles d'urbanisme qui ont bien souvent
poussés à l'étalement est donc conduit à
l' isolement et réorienter nos efforts
d'investissements vers les transports du
quotidien doit aussi adapter nos
services publics pour qu'ils
redeviennent des services de contact et
passe seulement pas uniquement numérique
humain tous ceux qui se sont exprimés
propose des solutions très concrètes
simple à mettre en oeuvre et dont je ne
crois pas qu'elle nécessite de grands
chambardements
nous devons aussi déployé une culture de
la simplicité la complexité surtout
quand alice quand il s'agit de droit
quand il s'agit d' allocation par
exemple cette complexité
elle finit toujours par exclure et donc
par éloigner j'ai demandé à vous
mesdames et messieurs les directeurs
d'administration centrale d'être présent
aujourd'hui je connais votre dévouement
et votre engagement au service de l'état
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
été marqués par les critiques parfois
injuste qui ont été formulées à votre
encontre
je veux leur dire à eux et à l'ensemble
de ceux qui pilotent l'état que nous
devons bâtir ensemble une organisation
et un fonctionnement qui repose sur la
recherche d'une production beaucoup
moins importante de normes est beaucoup
plus importante
deux solutions ou le service aux usagers
doit primer
c'est assez facile à formuler c'est
assez délicat à accomplir nous le savons
tous mais ça n'est pas parce que c'est
difficile il faut dire que du coup ça ne
serait pas important c'est essentiel la
troisième exigence c'est une exigence
démocratique
le président de la république l'a dit
nous ne sommes pas parvenu à réconcilier
les français avec ceux qui les dirigent
il faut d'être il faudrait être d'un
aveuglement absolue pour ne pas entendre
pour ne pas voir les mots très durs très
violent qu'une grande partie des
contributions utilise à l'encontre du
gouvernement des élus ou des
fonctionnaires
j'ai moi même dû apprendre à gouverner
avec cette défiance
parce que parfois la bonne foi ne suffit
pas la bonne foi c'est celle qui m'a par
exemple conduit à instaurer le 80 km
heure parce que je ne pouvais pas
accepter l'hécatombe quotidienne qui
brise des vies des familles d existence
je voulais sauver des vies on m'a accusé
de vouloir remplir des caisses
je ne me résigne pas abandonner cette
ambition en matière de sécurité routière
c'est une grande politique publique au
service de nos concitoyens à l'état
indispensable mais je dois apprendre à
composer avec la compréhension ou le
rejet de certains de nos concitoyens
renouer avec une forme de confiance
c'est le grand défi de notre génération
politique les français nous demandent
des choses simples la première c'est de
mieux identifier
qui fait quoi dans le mille feuilles
dans le mille feuilles actuelle et qui
ici pourrait ne pas les comprendre
la deuxième chose c'est de construire
les outils d'une démocratie plus
délibérative elle existe déjà à bien des
égards au niveau local pas depuis si
longtemps mais elle existe et elle se
développe elle reste assez largement
inventées au niveau de l'état nous nous
sommes collectivement rendu compte que
des structures qui étaient prévus à cet
effet n'ont pas permis d'organiser le
grand débat et qu'il a donc fallu en
imaginer d'autres le grand débat se
termine mais l'exigence de participation
demeure et le président l'a dit nous ne
pourrons plus gouverner comme avant
cette expérience elle doit nous être
utile pour bâtir une démocratie
participative au long cours enfin encore
une fois les français n'ont pas été
simpliste certains noms c'est la fin de
la démocratie représentative et
l'avènement de ce qui aurait pu être une
forme de démocratie directe et
médiatique permanente
ça n'est pas ce que les français veulent
ils sont exigeants ils veulent une
démocratie plus représentative plus
transparente plus efficace et une
exemplarité encore renforcé la dernière
exigence est une urgence une urgence
climatique dont les français ont une
claire conscience une des nombreuses
bonnes nouvelles de ce grand débat c'est
que les français à la différence de
nombreux autres peuples ne sont pas
climato sceptiques ils savent que ce qui
se joue en ce moment est essentielle
je crois que nous pouvons colis
collectivement être fiers de cette
lucidité fier de cette exigence nos
concitoyens nous disent qu'ils sont
prêts à changer de comportement dans un
grand nombre de domaines
en revanche ils ne veulent pas ils ne
veulent plus que des taxes leur dicte ce
qu'il doit faire et dans les cas où ils
peuvent l'envisager
ils veulent que leurs produits finances
des dispositifs d'accompagnement
ces messages nous les avons reçu cinq
sur cinq
fort et clair
comme on dit parfois ces quatre
orientations sans forcément faire
l'unanimité font globalement consensus
parmi les contributeurs
elles ont le mérite d'être clair ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'elles sont faciles à
atteindre
d'autant que et c'est bien naturel
ces contributions sont également
ressortir un certain nombre de paradoxes
ou de contradiction
ce n'est pas totalement anormal quand
plus d'un million et demi de personnes
s'expriment mais il faut évidemment en
tenir compte
tout l'enjeu va donc maintenant
consistait à passer de ces éléments de
consensus de ces éléments de consensus
sur les exigences que j'ai évoquées à
des compromis démocratique
pour atteindre ces objectifs
et ça c'est le travail de la démocratie
représentative il reviendra bien entendu
au président de la république de donner
les grandes orientations puis au
gouvernement de travailler avec le
parlement et ce travail devra évidemment
s'effectuer avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les élus locaux avec les acteurs
associatifs demain devant l'assemblée
nationale puis mercredi devant le sénat
j'aurai l'occasion d'en préciser les
enjeux
cet agenda des solutions il obéira
forcément à plusieurs échelles de temps
une chose ma part est certaine nous
sommes parvenus à une situation où
hésiter serait pire qu'une erreur ce
serait une faute
le besoin de changement et si radicale
que tout conservatisme tout frilosité
serait à mes yeux impardonnable
vous pouvez l'amener messieurs compter
sur ma détermination absolue sur celle
du gouvernement pour faire du succès du
grand débat une chance pour les français
une chance pour nos territoires
une chance pour notre avenir est une
chance pour la france
je vous remercie